what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
get in loser we're going shopping with
sophia and sistine stallone
we just become best friends yep
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the
unwaxed podcast with your favorite
sisters sophia and sistine stallone
and scarlett whoa you guys back you
don't see me back there
back by popular demand we have miss
scarlett stallone joining us
on this week's episode i just want to
say something scarlett i don't know if
you've read the comments on youtube
on our podcast review area
you are probably the most highly
demanded
guest i'm not kidding no she's being
serious
i'm a bit shocked yeah what and i'm i'm
glad okay
yeah you did good the first time
no you didn't admit you were a little
nervous and i don't believe i was so
nervous all right so how are you feeling
this time around
i'm shaking actually no i'm joking i'm
i'm a lot more comfortable
with this environment we're happy to
have you back and if you guys haven't
noticed
we're at a legitimate studio today look
at this
see my faces for us upgrading our lives
guess what
the audio sounds great now so none of
y'all
can tell us it sounds crappy so stop
complaining yes
thank you scarlett our bulldog but no
we're really happy we just found a
studio that is
in florida and it's awesome and we're
definitely going to keep using this
because
much easier setup than what we were
doing i feel like we're back
to our old ways we're a legit podcast
now before doing the zoom
interviews just wasn't cutting it for me
if you guys have been in an environment
when you're
at work and you feel that you're more
diligent and you're actually getting
yourself done and then when you're at
home you kind of feel lazy and you feel
slower yeah you have your like crop tops
on and then on the bottom half you have
like sweatpants and you're like ah
i'm 50 and when you're in the studio it
feels legitimate even though we still
have
crop tops on at work let's go
let's go sophia and i are currently
drinking a seltzer right now because we
thought you know what let's celebrate
let's celebrate
it's a tuesday it's a tequila tuesday if
you guys are not out tonight just
get some margaritas you better be
booking those reservations at the
mexican restaurant that's near your
house
let's get it also just before we jump
into the episode a quick reminder
to subscribe and i want to say something
real quick
a lot of people have been coming up to
sophia and i saying we love the podcast
we listen to the podcast well are you a
subscriber do you actually love the
podcast because you hit
subscribe we haven't heard from you so
please
we would really appreciate it i'm just
saying you're just saying
why don't you listen straight to their
face that's what i'm doing we're doing
right now with people right now so
please if you could subscribe on our
youtube channel
follow us on apple podcast follow us on
spotify
follow us on instagram at unwaxedpodcast
we have a twitter but sophia doesn't use
it she's got to get better with that i
don't like twitter
and if you could write a review and
leave five stars that is the only way we
will answer your unsolicited advice if
you leave your question in the ratings
in review
section we actually do love all the
questions that you guys have been asking
and we will answer them all of them so
if you do it
let's get in to our weekly update ladies
and gentlemen
sophia kick us off y'all
guess where we were this weekend once
again y'all
my freaking yummy it was my first time
here we go
drink all day play all night
yeah yeah let's get it pop it okay sofia
and i have been
little miami fiends a little bit i don't
know if you guys remember from last
week's episode we were
throwing out the idea of possibly moving
there because we fallen in love with the
place
right but you know there is a difference
between us doing a miami weekend
and us actually living in miami and i
feel like we need to probably go to
miami
when it's a very calm weekend and really
get to know the place but
this miami trip was extra special
because we brought
scarlet with us and no told me you guys
we did not take her to the places you
think
we're taking her too we're responsible
yeah we are so responsible she's
drinking
flat water yeah we're good sisters we're
good sisters we would never put you in a
a bad situation
like
i have to say that was really exciting
because i think this was our first
sister trip normally we're always with
the parents which is great
but you know sometimes it's nice just to
be with the kids it definitely started
off a little rocky you have to admit
slightly slightly rocky yeah why don't
you explain why
okay so we started our road trip i got
my nails done
and then it ended up being having to
delay our
road trips so we hit the traffic
it turned out to be a two and a half
hour drive instead of a one hour drive
some of my sisters were a little mad at
me in the car ride
anyways was it worth it for the nails
yeah so cute
no you told me you didn't like the color
yesterday no i did it's just a little
scratchy they kind of messed up so then
we ended up
at two two hotels because they just
didn't work for us
it was a mess but i feel like that's how
you gotta go with miami you just gotta
roll with the punches it never turns out
the way
you want it but we did live together in
the same room
for three days straight and i don't know
if you guys know how much
stuff girls have especially us maybe
your girlfriend i think i
will meet up but your your girl's here
we got a lot of makeup oh we got a lot
of clothes we got a lot of hair
we also have like an unhealthy amount of
things
yeah it was really funny i was listening
to this one podcast and this guy kept
saying girls just love
stuff just this love things they collect
so many things we have so much crap that
we brought with us
for two days you we could have started a
store genuinely
we were a sephora yeah we were full on
we were come on in
wear a mask but you can come into our
sephora but i have to say
that we did agree upon this men
i don't like sharing a room with you
tell me straight up sistine
this is facts this is facts it's not
it's not got nothing we were thinking
about it
when you're sharing a room with anyone
depending on your level of
comfortability there's always that
awkwardness of
what you gotta do in the morning after
your good old cup of joe
yes right do i have to spell it out for
y'all i think we're all on the same page
here okay
and even as sisters you know
respectfully we go
we'll go in the lobby we'll go you know
what why don't we always talk about [ __ ]
on this podcast i know we always talk
about [ __ ] in this pocket you just told
me that i was like pooping in the
hallway a couple minutes ago even before
that no but i'm telling you it's
stressful
it's just it's stressful when i share
room with a guy
especially if it's a guy that you're
kind of for seeing or it's the first
time you
like are in the same room with a guy
consecutively what do you do you
i look like a monster in the morning i
don't want to see your face i don't like
you actually taught me something what
did i teach you
okay if you go to the bathroom oh god
and you do the number two oh my god you
get a lighter you
you get the lighter you in a match light
it up
blow out the match and then the smoke
from the mask it cancels the smell
my girlfriend is a joke but kind of
smart
got me these things called uh the drops
that you put in the toilet what are they
called
they're like they're called like this is
a drink lemon drop but it smells like
lemons i forgot what it was
oh i'm not gonna i don't i don't really
know the term for it but you basically
do it while you're flushing and then
also lemons
come out no but it's it's so funny
because the length that we will go to to
avoid
avoid it avoid them even knowing that we
would smell
at all is insane because girls don't go
to the back i will go to the walgreens
across the street
i will keep this uh stereotype and myth
going because i won't do it i'll give an
example sophia and i
one time went to such dramatic lengths
to just avoid the situation as a whole
we set an alarm at 6 30 in the morning
6 30 because this is our theory we go
okay let's get out of bed before they
wake up
they're hungover we'll sneak out we'll
go to the lobby
drink a huge cup of starbucks sit there
wait maybe do a few laps around the
hotel yeah when we feel it's ready we go
climb back into bed of course put some
concealer on before you get back yes
mascara because your eyelashes are just
perfect and we just wake up
skinny and beautiful beautiful
and you guys can't tell me right now
that none of you have had that
experience where either you just can't
cause you can't
or you go to great lengths so you can't
i feel like we're venting but if anyone
has
good tips tips let us know because we
definitely need to pull out your girls i
think it's also
i would say before when you stay with a
guy versus your sisters or just even a
girl
it's like the smell is different like i
was raised around girls
so i don't really know what guys
routines are like i know that they have
usually just those girls
i'll tell you what i've seen with guys
guys have cologne
they have an axe deodorant
or whatever and then they have their
comb i feel like those are the three
things i see
oh and a toothbrush it's true why do
they have two toilets
a lot of combs and they have a shaver
i bring it somewhere and sometimes they
have it's always in the same black brown
bag
but a tiny little travel bag i bring at
least
four leaving t-shirts my bag
can i tell you how much stuff i have i
remember i went on a trip when i was
like going to uh
what's it called uh it was one of those
day trips where you go when you're in
middle school joshua tree yeah one of
those traps someone grabbed my bag and
said do you have a dead body in there
that's how she brought a full-on duffel
bag i brought a duffle bag to go to
joshua because girls
like stuff and you never know if you're
going to need your eyelash glue in
middle school
you never know if you're going to need
it on a camping trip we don't know we
don't know
um i would also like to talk about
something that just seems to
be a reoccurring incidence with me in
terms of
drunk girls at restaurants oh yeah this
always
happens to me it does i don't know why
maybe maybe i've got a sign on my back
but i'm always the target for a drunk
girl
getting in a fight oh it's so sad every
time
no she is usually the one that's more of
a bulldog sistine's like just
kind of standing there i'm just standing
there cesine doesn't ask first thing
sophia
sophia won't be afraid to get in a
girl's face if she pushes one of us
accidentally or
or cuts us in line whereas i i say
please cut me because i get nervous of
confrontation right
so i'm standing there it's funny that
people think that i'm the nice one
and then the [ __ ] one when in fact i
will be the one to call you out if
you're being rude sean
tell me to stop yeah i'm the one that
tells her to stop and then
just say i'm a mute i'm amused even if
it's a chill night you guys i'm not
saying that we're headed to these places
where we're raging face or whatever
no this is just like a nice
i'm minding my own business i got some
new pants on
they're beige i'm feeling cute all of a
sudden
out of nowhere out of nowhere you know
when girls get so drunk and guys
that their body weight just triples
because they're so intoxicated it's like
you can't stop this moving force
that's what happened here she backed
into me right
elbowed me i'm an inch away from falling
some dude catches me
her drink goes all over my new pants and
the best part is since they're based it
looked like i pissed myself it was all
in the right spot for a pissing moment
so why does this always happen yeah and
even
that happened to you a couple years ago
where we were out
and this girl it was her birthday i
remember we had a restaurant and we
literally just stood up for a second
and bless bless the lord that there was
a couch right there
this girl i think thought cysteine was a
tree
no this is what happened i was standing
next to a fern
she would stay next to a fern i could
have been the fern i you know like i
looked dangly i looked the same yes you
were
i think you're wearing green as well
yeah honestly she could have just she
couldn't
she could have fair enough fair enough
fair enough
slender man over here so i'm standing
next to this fern right
this girl reaches out her hand because
she's so intoxicated trying to catch on
to the fern
instead confuses a branch for my neck
yes and i get wwe smackdown
on the couch one second sistine sexted
me one second she is flat on her back
legs on my head a mess
what the hell i it was the yeah honestly
and the girl looks at me her friend and
she goes
i'm just so sorry and walks away and i
look at the scene traumatized
i'm still rolling there's like a poor
little puppy on the ground like
everyone in the room went where does
this thing i think i did piss myself
that time
that time yeah there was no drink there
that was just you okay let's talk about
scarlet a little bit
our guest is here you know let's just
say it as it is scarlet
when it rains it pours doesn't it when
it does
baby scarlet update us on your dating
life what's happening
okay okay um i guess
my dating life i'm currently single
she said single for the first time
by the way the last time scarlett was on
the show i'm just gonna reiterate
she was in a relationship great
relationship by the way great amazing
boy
but now we're all single
people i don't know if you've oh i don't
know
i was in a relationship for like almost
about three years
and mine only lasts about three weeks so
that's something this is uh she lives
vicariously throughout this is good
i mean i have to admit this single life
it's good do you like it
it's not so bad not so i'm not
complaining
you know it's interesting because sophie
and i always try to give you dating
advice and always try to give you tips
and
obviously you don't want to hear it all
the time because you think that you know
what's best but
you got to listen to the sensai masters
a few times you know i
am but you guys are talking about when
you give me advice you guys talk about
dating i don't want a date no no i don't
want anything that has to do with dating
what i'm saying is sometimes you don't
understand what we're saying until you
experience it yourself
for example when sophia said when it
rains it pours
you will fully go through a drought and
have no one reaching out to you have no
men and all the sudden you have like 17
at all at the same time dude with a
raise of pores
have you guys had that before where you
were so single and your soul on your ex
screw it i don't want anybody anymore
and then all of a sudden
a follow request a message
a dm a snapchat and it's like what i
don't
how did you get my number there's only
seven days in the week you don't want to
do those 12 points
i don't understand about your generation
is that you guys
don't need to get me started you guys
talk through snapchat i know you're
going to say that
what is the deal with that i think it's
a weird way because
i think guys that are probably under 20.
if you're 21 and older and you're asking
for a girl's snap
that's kind of weird i think okay i feel
like that's very important i think of a
guy i was talking to a guy who was about
29 years old
i met him on hinge
and we'll call him chef boyardee oh my
god
he was a chef if you didn't get the joke
he was about 28 29 and he goes can i
have your snap
and if you're over the age of 20 and
you're asking girls for this now you
simply just want a nude
that is that's all it is for but your
age so also
i think guys also get very nervous about
texting and they're also really nervous
about like
what then don't be on a date don't text
the girls listen
listen i feel like that guys like to go
on snapchat because when you're texting
and you swipe
out their text is gone so they're not
really afraid to say what they want that
just screams cheating all over the place
bingo because i thought in my head i
said okay i'm trying to think of the
rationale
to text on snapchat because when you
text on snapchat if you don't know it
goes away
yeah and so it sounds to me that it it
lacks commitment or there's no right as
if
asking for a girl's number is too much
commitment yeah
i like it when a guy asks for my number
rather than myself that's what i'm
saying
yeah because i was just asked for a
number and i was like snapchat
no no no on dm it went from dm
and then they asked okay let's cut it
out let's do like
stop the dm let's go on let me get your
number and i'm like oh
okay yeah expert i like that that is so
much interesting that
the these generations coming up it's now
you only meet through dm i wonder what
it's going to be next yeah i mean it's
just so strange to me i never thought
that
do you think that i feel like there are
no manly men anymore everyone's scared
to just straight up ask for what you
want
it's really it's just a weird generation
good luck scarlett i don't know why i'm
saying that i'm a life years older i'm
in that generation too
um okay so last week was it last week or
the week before
two weeks ago two weeks ago two episodes
ago go back and listen
we did an episode called sophia scariest
stalker and we thought
let's throw out a new segment out there
let's do something fun that people like
story time segments because we have a
lot of stories and there's a lot of
things we've mentioned we wanted to
discuss but we don't really know a good
way to transition into it so sistine
thought of this idea and said
let's do a story time let's have a good
sentiment where we just talk about it
and you guys
wow i loved it the response was so good
so
we're gonna make it a a weekly thing
yeah and thank you to the guys that took
note that i don't like stalkers and i
don't like men
over the age of 40 dming me oh
please don't damn well my dms are open
boys come on in come on in
so sophia gave her stalker story last
week it was two thumbs up
thank you 98 on rotten tomatoes i had a
little ptsd but i'm do it for the
audience
i do it for the videos for the podcast i
got a little anxiety but it's okay
they're enjoying it this week
i have brought in a wonderful story one
that i've had written down i've wanted
to share
it took some convincing and i'm so happy
we've heard i'm glad you're drinking too
so
it'll loosen the blow a little bit i
know so here we go
what should we call this we'll call this
the windshield wipers
story how about deer in headlights we'll
call it
we'll call it googly eyes we'll call it
cones against the glasses
what are you talking about here we go
a few years ago i was dating this guy
and he was super hot but that's besides
the point that's besides the point
what's up i don't know who she's talking
about and
i was hanging out with him in my living
room and i saw sophia
through the window i remember i was i
was so hyper that day because i got some
really good news and i was jumping all
over the place and
i see sophia across the window way and i
thought it would be really funny to
surprise her
by flashing my boobs at her for two
seconds right and putting it down
right obviously my back is to the guy
it's just for sophia and i was just
girl was going nuts i was doing
cartwheels whatever sophia sees it
she laughs through the window she
decides to return
the favor of course not knowing that my
now
ex was in the room so what i thought was
funny because 169
if we see each other through the window
we'll flip each other off or we'll flash
each other just really quick
but i decided she said no no let's kick
it up a notch
let's get into it let's kick it into
high gear i've never done it like this
she's never i was so shocked she decides
to
not only lift her shirt and flash me
back
but do a running head start towards the
window
smash her tits up on the glass
and start to figure eight start to do
some circles she was doing an ice
skating routine
with her boobs on the glass and i start
my face
i freak out and i start laughing i
didn't know what to be scared for you
or or laugh at you because he was in the
room
and i look over at him he looks back at
me
he looks back at sophia and i and he was
trying to act like he didn't see it wait
can i explain
so after i do that whole show hi gabe
scene
first class seats to my titties um
since steve looks at me like i just
killed someone and goes
he's here like basically wording he's
here and
you who and i turn my head a little bit
and i see his face pop out and his eyes
were so
his eyes nearly popped out of his head
all he did was literally have the most
uncomfortable smile i have ever seen
and he decided to wave
no no not cover his eyes no no not turn
around
thought waving at me yeah didn't think
oh i didn't see anything would have been
a good option
he decided to say oh god what's up other
sister how you doing no he basically
said
i have two sisters that just flashed
themselves at each other i saw
both of their boobs my girlfriend's
standing over her sister's another
what's the best thing to do to make it
less
weird wave wave not
run he waves like is this how you guys
communicate with each other sophia's
face looked like she just saw a ghost
she was so so humiliated i wasn't even
upset i wasn't
i didn't care because well you knew it
wasn't this i didn't yeah there's no lie
and i i thought it was just so funny now
also seeing you get so uncomfortable by
it was so
and when i get uncomfortable i'll ask
the person 100 times like
did you see that are you okay i kept
saying are you okay
like i just gave up i think he's okay
i don't know if you got it it wasn't i
don't think it was a preface it wasn't
like a
three second thing she was there for at
least 15
seconds i was there for now you may be
questioning me why didn't i cut her off
but i was just
i was here for a good time in a long
time i was just enjoying the show so
that was one of
the funniest moments the best moment was
when i was doing it and i was looking at
your face
and you were laughing well i was making
one of those faces that could have been
shot or left i was like
yeah she was like what is she doing
and so i kept going okay well that
proud of you love that story so one of
our most popular youtube videos which
still today
and people actually i just remember this
somebody came up to us recently and said
that this was something they watched
just to get to know us more yeah
and it was our witch sister video and i
feel like we've brought this up before
thanks to me
yes i started it so why don't you
explain why you started it how you
started it
your youtube channel okay so freshman
year
i was really into like the
typical like jake paul like the vlog
i i i kind of forgot the names by now
but i was really into youtube
and i wanted to start my own channel
because you know i was
as a kid does yeah i think it does like
everyone has like
a secret youtube channel but i was just
more vocal about it
anyways i did it freshman year i
personally didn't it's a lot more
work than it is i thought it was going
to be so
easy just to make a video edit it done
bam
post wow it is hard it's a lot of time
and hard work and think you know but you
decided to
quit after making this one video called
which system i started i did like
two videos nah you did like one but you
got embarrassed
yeah i got really embarrassed because i
realized how much of a dork i was and i
was just
no i thought you were way cooler than
you're you're making yourself out to be
i think what you were embarrassed about
was kids in class would pull up the
video
and they did and watch it and they did i
was in chapel and they
fully that's freshman boy i know i just
i just didn't i don't know why i didn't
like the attention on me yeah i started
a youtube
anyways um i wanted to
obviously didn't get a lot of views so
bam
pulled out my sister card
got more views so i created not i didn't
create but
i thought it would be a good idea to do
a witch sister video just to get to
know all of us and kind of just you know
content brought it back we're about to
play another game of witch sister on the
podcast but we're kicking it up a notch
we're not gonna do who has the biggest
fee no no we're gonna do something a
little bit more fun so
and i think the best way to go about it
is we'll switch off reading the
questions
and then we'll say three two one and
we'll just say the name since
not everyone's listening or watching and
because i was going to say let's point
but i think just say the name of the
first person you think of
sophia's rules let's play let's do it
this is good
here it goes welcome to witch sister
with
your favorite sisters including scarlet
yo
and scarlet which sister is most likely
to be caught telling a lie
three two one scarlet easy peasy which
sister is most likely to snitch on other
siblings three
two one sophia yeah yeah yeah
um which sister is most likely to get
punched in the face
three two one sophia sophia
is gonna i don't i want to punch she
wants to punch and she would get punched
i would because i would insult you yeah
all right
most likely i like to defend my sisters
and i like to defend a situation
okay most likely to get offended by a
joke
three two one sophia sistine
most likely to fail a driving test three
two one sophia
i failed it three times she failed it
three times you guys if for some reason
you're ever in a car with her just don't
i'm getting better just tuck and roll i
just tuck and roll i get better i get
better yeah
all right uh scratch the next one most
likely to network at a funeral
three two one sistine
i'd say me for sure i don't know sister
would say like see someone she knows
from that industry thing and she'll just
kind of like yeah like hi i'm sistine
and
you gotta do what you gotta do yeah i
don't blame you
which sister is most likely to become a
famous actor
or actress three two one scarlett
scarlett you've done more work i haven't
started anything but you
want to be the actor of the family yeah
you do so steen's kind of more she likes
acting but i would say she
also likes 100 scarlet this you say this
is your passion you got to manifest it
yeah you can't say that
all right most likely to marry someone
their friends and family hate
oh three two one
really i think yeah i don't agree sophia
you really need our approval for people
that you date i've dated some
sus individuals oh yeah and you guys
tell me no i feel like scarlet
oh i didn't see that absolutely not
absolutely not if you guys don't even
like one of my friends i don't
i talk actually i totally take it
completely
i get so worried about my sisters oh
this one is such an easy one most likely
to have a crush on an anime character
three two one scarlett i just
feel like i'm starting to become that
though yeah we're very intimidated
anime no i got them into anime that's
what happened and the attitude scarlett
has about animals
you guys claim that you guys oh i love
anime no you are making fun of me and
that's nice for sure
it's so funny because anime has been
around forever it's
carla acts like she invented it and so
if we say that we like it she goes well
i like
because you never give me credit we gave
you credit for telling us about it but i
give myself credit for she made fun of
me for a while here's that fight we were
talking about i got sistine more into it
because i was forced to sit with me read
the next question the next one
is who is most likely to stay home on
friday night
three two one scene absolutely sistine
you guys are not to say me because
recently i have no idea
you're such a social butterfly you know
those memes of all of those zodiac
things
and it says for cancer when uh cancer's
friday night plans get cancelled and i'm
in bed smiling
that's me yes that always happens
all right most likely to stay up all
night thinking
three two one sophia all of us no so
literally yeah i've had multiple nights
where i'll think of
can i guys have you had this one you've
stayed up in the middle of night
thinking about something from
two years ago oh oh yeah and it keeps it
up for days
i just popped two melatonin and i'm good
so you pop like four melatonins yeah
they're so difficult
cysteine has some weird melatonin
addiction you know i i
canceled my biotin addiction and now
we're on that melatonin by the way
don't eat biotin it gives you breakouts
and
throws your hair in odd places yeah you
guys i started looking like a sasquatch
i i was recommending it before and i
highly recommend it you don't do it
kylie hartman stop doing it
most likely to go on a blind date
arranged by their mom
three two one so this is a personal
attack it's
happening this is literally happening
right now hey how do you guys feel about
that that your mom is giving you a guy's
number
is that weird kind
of at a level of desperation where it
doesn't matter you know what
you know what i think our moms i thought
it was weird at first
but i think your mom has the best
intention and if you look at the person
you're like all right i'm into it
i don't see why not if you're super
single
most likely to fall in love with their
teacher in college
wait i'm so split on this because i know
but i feel like
oh okay three two one sophia
sophia sophia sophia all of the erotica
novels i read are about
to tell you right now you like the
student teacher
like the scandal of it i was just
literally successful
i would fall nerdy if a guy's like
oh okay romeo and juliet going to learn
about that today
he's like some taller than some dude
wearing glasses come on i fall in love
clothes are off so he is done yeah
most likely to end up in prison three
two one scarlett i guess i'm just
[ __ ] up right now
yeah what would you end up because why
would you end up in prison because i
what would you do i just like it's just
something about my personality that's
just
okay so what would be a crime if
everyone jumps scarlet will jump
that's kind of scary i feel like
scarlett would be before breaking and
entering or trespassing sometimes i
think it would be like yeah
yeah i know this sounds so bad but i
used to steal a lot when i was like four
oh cute little klepto kit over here so i
wouldn't be surprised at cops
sorry mom most likely to get married
first don't look at me don't eat into
one sophia
[Music]
psychic said i'm gonna get married first
does not mean it's gonna happen no it's
not true because we've been saying this
for a while
and you fall in love with people easier
and you'll probably find the one
pretty soon me on the other hand i am as
fickle as they come i will like you one
moment
and we'll shut you off the next i really
hope not i want to wait i like the
single life right now
so i'm not playing you're 18. i know i
like it
and that was witch sister and i hope you
guys liked it i think it was
almost as good as the last one um but
you know
it was pretty good we didn't hate each
other after this so yeah we're gonna
scream at each other in the car
yeah i'm just kidding so we're really
excited to transition to this
favorite topic of ours which is
unsolicited advice and i know cece
mentioned it in the beginning but
apple podcast write your question five
star and we will answer it
and this one actually came recently so
i'm really excited to answer it and
maybe scarlett can try to give some
insight get some insight too
this is from hashtag bo b-e-a-u
hello um she said love y'all so much
oh my god thank you thank you for
listening to and thank you for
submitting correctly
how long should the taking it slow stage
last
love from houston you know what's funny
is sistine i read this oh yeah and we
did come into this
saying we should either be
careful about what we say or we should
just be very honest and i think we
should just be honest about
what we believe is our opinion and what
we believe is true
because you guys can just like what we
said before don't take it personally
but how we feel about this question and
how we're gonna answer it is for us
and also based off of our experience
exactly
so you can take it or leave it and it
doesn't mean we judge anybody any other
way
but because frankly i judge myself for
my own choices so i don't need y'all
judging me so we're just gonna be
straight up and honest about it so
from my experience i've done it both
ways
right so i've done the not taking it
slow
and jumped right into it right away
and i've also made it way
two made it like it's a thing made him
wait
one to two months and from my experience
it really depends on what you're looking
for if you're just looking to have fun
and you like the tension and it's flirty
and it's cheeky
then you can do it whenever it feels
right for you
right but if you're looking for a
serious long-term relationship
and it also depends on the age that
you're at because the younger they are
the more immature they are
obviously i take that back there are
some 35 year old 40 men that are just
super immature as well
but from my experience taking it slow
building that relationship really
getting to know each other and having
that stage is
pivotal and vital in order to have
a long-lasting relationship because i
don't have much obviously you guys have
a lot more experience than me
however my three-year relationship
happened because i took it as slow as
possible because that was just my rate i
was just
i was only 16 when we started and
i liked to get to know him and take it
slow and however
he he accepted it and if he doesn't like
that then he's not the guy for you
yeah and i agree with that i think from
my own experience
i've always said take it slow i like to
get to know the person more and i think
there's a beauty in that and i think
there is also another type of
intimacy in that it was when you get to
know those person's
highs and lows and what makes them laugh
what makes them angry
and i think it just builds a type of
relationship for sure
and we can't sit here and say okay you
have to wait no two months for them to
respect you
that's not what we're saying because
everyone's on their own timeline i've
done what i've considered taking it slow
three weeks
and that was because we saw each other
maybe every other day but if you're
seeing this person
once a week or once every other week
then yeah it could drag on a bit more
totally so again whatever works for you
i've done it both ways and from our
experience we just find that depending
on what you're looking for
yeah waiting is good and plus the cat
mouse game the anticipation the build-up
i find is the best
and she's asking how long should it take
there's no timeline yeah there is no
timeline i know for me i have
fallen for a person within five dates
i've fallen for a person within
two months three months mine's like six
months see and i think that
i think i like waiting personally and i
think there's a
beauty in waiting and that but that's
what i'm looking for
yeah unless you do not want to be in a
relationship at all and you just want to
have fun
do whatever you want but also i've heard
so many stories of people just
hooking up on the first date and they
end up married yeah so it really
honestly
we're saying take it slow but it just
depends on
your level of comfortability and again
going back to what we had just
previously talked about
trust your gut and trust the decisions
that you make because they're right for
you
yeah so we can't sit here and say this
is what you should do because it's the
right thing to do
these are choices that we're making that
because they're good friends you can
gauge from talking to someone for a
couple weeks
exactly what maybe the timeline needs to
be
if you want them to be serious so go off
of your own gut instinct we have womanly
instincts and even if you're a guy i
think it's the same way
um you guys know you know what's right
no you do know what's right for you i
hope that was a good answer
yeah i hope that helped in some way and
respect your bodies and
and respect your heart protect your
souls ladies and gentlemen
i think that just about wraps up this
episode yeah
yeah yeah how do you feel i feel good i
want to come back
i want to say actually a lot of people
are saying makes call out a regular
yeah really if you know what scarlett if
you write yourself a segment on the show
100 percent really yeah after you will
take my segment
if it's good yeah if not anything you
write why not
scarlett i thought we were running a
show here oh mike scott this is a
production look we're officially in a
studio we found a studio somewhere
um thank you guys so much for tuning in
this week
uh you know we're hoping the sound
quality is better we really appreciate
you guys listening make sure you
subscribe make sure you write in we love
hearing from you guys
follow us on instagram at unwax podcast
scarlet any final words
i'll miss you guys i'll see you later
happy tuesday
bye everyone from all of us here at the
show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week